for the second time in two days armed  gunmen exchanged fire with airport  security personnel there are conflicting  reports about how many militants were  involved in the attack on a training  center a kilometer away from the main  airport building the army sent in  soldiers to assist airport staff on  Monday a siege at the same Airport left  dozens dead the Taliban said they  carried out that attack to avenge the  death of their former chief hakimullah  mehsud who was killed in a US drone  strike last year Pakistan responded to  the assault by launching air strikes on  Taliban positions on the Afghan border  following today's attack flights have  once more been suspended and passengers  have been evacuated from the airport the  fear is the Taliban may be planning more  attacks